this is a production of Cornell
University so everybody thanks for
joining this is the first weekend our
golf symposium webinar series and this
is obviously in partnership with the GCS
a a New York chapter so recently formed
chapter for those not in New York we
kind of consolidated a couple regional
chapters recently into the GCS a and Y
so we're putting this on in partnership
with then trying to recreate the
educational day that we unfortunately
had to cancel early in March so you know
big and big thanks to Suzanne miss who's
the chapter administrator saw her on
today she's helped us logistically kind
of organized this stuff so today we've
got a Frank Rossi starting with some
data driven management you know
considering the pandemic circumstances
and this is our lineup for the upcoming
weeks we're gonna have Doug so that from
Wisconsin talking about optimizing
nitrogen fertility you next week and
then in two weeks we're gonna have golf
course architect Eamonn Andrews on with
us talk a little bit about a minimal
design aspect so we also did want to
thank the partners with the GCS a and Y
so there are platinum sponsors we have
Andre and Sun first turf and ornamental
grassland Harold's so you know us here
at Cornell we what worked with these
guys too and leaned on them for support
in our research the gold sponsors Finch
BSF pup irrigation technologies and MTE
and then some silver sponsors as well
right so Ewing Syngenta nutrient
solutions turf and soil Diagnostics
weber golf and turf and dry jacks so a
big thanks to all the sponsors here who
still supporting this virtual education
day I think with that Frank I'll hand it
off to you and we can now we can get
started
thanks very much Carl and another big
shout out to the GCS a the new GCS a of
New York let me put this one away and
get the other one sorry about that yeah
big shout out to them we're gonna have a
we'll have a longer conversation about
that when we get to the data driven
component of this but all of you that
know me
no no we try to start out with something
a little bit funny or positive or cute
and here we go
my man fad right away this is what it
looked like outside of Terry Hills out
there in the in western New York one of
the three associations that came
together to start the Golf Course
superintendent's Association in New York
and and we we are looking forward to
welcoming the other chapters dad it
makes sense to consolidate like this
because look at the cool things that can
happen as a result we can all get
together during a global pandemic anyway
here we go
thanks for shouting out that anyway I
don't know inspiration I look for some
I'm one of those sorts of people feel
like we have a certain amount of
responsibility I know I do
I'm enormous ly privileged and luckily
lucky to have been had a chance to work
hard and do the things I do and I think
for those of us that can do that I think
sometimes we've got to go beyond our
best and what's required and I think
there's a air of social responsibility
that we're all being asked to do and
this is our little part as we start our
fifth conversation together during the
global pandemic all right let's do a
little housekeeping here as we like to
do and I don't want to wade too deep in
these waters there may be a more recent
update these things are updated
sometimes multiple times during the day
but this is what came out that that left
some confusion last week it was still
there on April 21st this I think
provides you know some it looked
confusing to me essential service such
as ground keeping to avoid hazardous
conditions does cutting the greens as an
eighth of an inch count as a hazardous
condition so this was obviously greatly
ambiguous and again the lobbying efforts
and all the advocacy efforts at the
Statehouse from an economic perspective
really talking about the value of golf
in New York led senator Daphne
Jordan to write a letter on behalf of
the golf industry that that basically
was saying listen we we think
individuals can access the use of carts
without them
of course employees that should be fine
okay well maybe that's something you
should think about and then with proper
social distancing and no employees other
than limited groundskeeping now again I
don't know what clarification of limited
groundskeeping means that certainly
worthy of discussion before we move into
data-driven but it's been the approach
we've been taking all along that really
what I think you have to look at what
you're doing in some ways on your golf
course a little bit differently then
maybe you have in the past and you may
be forced to do it because of money you
may be forced to do it because of Labor
there may be a lot of reasons but but
obviously these are the kinds of sort of
government over or overarching things
that that provide some boundaries for
the things we do now
you know I'm an observer like many of
you on Twitter and a part this
participant sometimes and I really liked
what what mid the Michigan GCS a just
put out you know this is the economic
story this is the story look we just
want to make you aware there's a lot of
land a lot of money to charity into the
economy Michiganders uh-huh and we look
forward to opening as soon as it's
appropriate appropriate I don't know
that's like essential this is a great I
mean it's I think that says the right
that's the right sentiment right we want
as we open if we're open we want to do
things that are appropriate right so
just so you know a reminder about your
Dec pesticide license in New York State
right I thought I'd remind everybody
since we're talking about to the golf
course superintendent supreme you know
at this point in New York State because
of our webinar today
the Dec is really cutting everybody a
fair amount of slack here if you if your
certification lapsed on or after
November 1st so all the way back to
November 1st
you can continue if you're able to work
to use that license until the order or
any extensions are issued 60 days after
the expiration of that order so you'll
see you got a little bit of time this
you know I don't believe in Carl
continues I think to support this that
the
is not currently in the mood to approve
credits yet that I'm aware of and we'll
see if that's gonna change over time all
right let's talk about golf openings the
National Golf Foundation continues to
provide really great data for the golf
industry about the business of golf and
I think this is a fascinating topic for
me as a biological science scientist I
don't really know a lot about business
which is good because I ask really
stupid questions that sometimes well I
didn't think about that before so if you
see the way that the golf courses are
opening and closing right
nobody was closed in March March 21st
now the weather might not have been very
good but here we are on the 21st 23rd
24th and we're still under some
weirdness here in New York State now
let's look at another way this is using
census data each of these colored
regions and I believe let's look here
there's so there's I think this is one
two three four five six seven eight nine
so there's nine census regions maybe
there's ten something like that so this
is organized by census region right so
let's look at this out so that's April 6
so here's April 6th sorry oh there we go
April 6th April 13th you could see right
now the the northern courses are
starting to open and then this is the
big news for us in the Northeast right
the the closures of golf courses in this
region around the epicenter right now in
the United States is is experiencing a
pretty significant downturn at a time
when these months are could be 40
percent of our entire season so these
are the kinds of things that are driving
the discussion balancing between safety
and operating and and I want to come
down on it you know I don't care this
isn't up to people like me but if you
guys are going to operate my our
responsibility is that we all do it
smartly they play smartly and we manage
it smartly so let's just begin to talk
about this in our covert analysis today
and then
get into a discussion with Kyle about
using data about a BA BW and then we'll
talk a little bit more about our topic
for today and of course want to have
discussion in between there as it's
warranted okay so so this is what it
looks like this was a picture in the
paper in Minnesota
Minnesota's opened up now Minnesota is
in fact the Scandinavia Sweden and
Norway of the United States so this
isn't new for to the Scandinavian
culture and I don't mean that
disparagingly it's just a nature of
those cultures and their social
distancing appropriately on the putting
surface there right I want to draw your
attention to an interesting Cornell
resource right if you're going to open
up right if you're going to open up as a
golf course in New York State what do
you need to know now obviously the
things you need to know on the golf
course but the Cornell population Center
has put together a really nice website
here looking at demographic and health
vulnerability right you know it's out
enough of course the epicenter is in a
New York City area but if you look at
things like how who you are and your
pre-existing conditions is related to
kovat it's about a 42% correlation 42%
at a time you can explain kovat problems
with who you are demographically and and
how vulnerable you know now this is
worth knowing because you think well
rural counties are safe but if you look
at this you see some of the rule Kerry
is actually your problem addict and if
you look at the way demographics are
looked at from a vulnerability
perspective as you open if you're open
it would be really good to be able to
talk to the people that are playing golf
about these kinds of things because this
ultimately until any kind of medical
solution comes along ultimately is the
most vulnerable among us and we should
at least know if our golf course is
operating in that county you know
obviously everybody's gonna take an
amount of care but wouldn't it be nice
to say well we're taking extra care
because we have a vulnerable population
I believe that's the kind of social
responsibility as we're thinking about
operating our businesses that we're also
thinking now I don't have to tell you
70% of the rounds in America are
performed by people over the age of 55 I
mean most people who played his game by
a each not over 80 but by age could be
potentially more vulnerable and this is
important and I think to something the
front of the house is going to have to
do in golf course situations where maybe
the PGA professional has to do this or
maybe the club managers have to do this
but somebody is gonna have to know what
kinds of pre-existing health conditions
you have in some way as you try to keep
people safe and distance on the Goethals
all right so operating the golf course
right so in in short order as as
expected by a golf course
superintendents problem-solvers by
nature all of you are going to figure
out ways to do this so I go fishing
around for things like this and Greg
Austin the president of the Canadian
Golf Course superintendent's based out
of BC British Columbia right Vancouver
British Columbia
reports on this wonderful draft that all
the Allied Golf Association's got
together in the British Columbia
province to write how we're going to do
and it's a nice 24 25 page document Carl
has all the links that he's normally
going to put in the chat bays and other
places where we're going to put it up
there make sure you take a look at this
as we start to build these things and
maybe these things are happening in
other places but what I like about this
is this got into detail now okay you're
a golf course superintendent you're an
assistant you're just working on a golf
course right just think about this part
of this one one one section of one page
of a 24 page 25 page document
look at all the things that have to get
sanitized and disinfected now on a
regular basis but this is going to take
time and my experience so far is we have
fewer people not more people and so if
we're going to work even if we have a
staff to do the work you're gonna have
to think about a proportion 20 30 10 I
don't know
percentage of your hours that are gonna
have to be allotted to clean everything
I was talking to Craig Cochrane the
other day in preparation for a new
frankly speaking episode came along and
he likened
you know Jim protocol got clean
everything you know you use it you clean
it yeah before you get on it you're
cleaning you get off it you clean it
it's you know it's one of those Jim
protocol things which I think it's a
good analogy for a lot of guys who you
know irregular Jim visitors the new
jersey superintendents also have a
really good response I've tried to talk
about the regional responses to these
things over the first couple of sessions
here and the New Jersey guys came out
with a really good little thing from
easy go about cleaning and sanitizing
guys off cars and equipment a nice four
or five page
listen I'm opinion less on whether we
should open it I that it's not up to me
but I'm telling you if golf is open and
operating and you eyes are managing
these operations and trying to cut the
grass and prep the place never mind
what's happening at the front of house
but you're just trying to keep your
things in order right you're gonna have
to know these protocols and have some
guidelines for how you're going to do it
and my suggestion is it's probably gonna
have to be written out Jonathan Haywood
one of the guys that I follow I don't
follow a lot of folks on Twitter one of
the guys I do Jonathan Haywood's at the
Morris County Golf Club he says his
staff that is down 40% for this time of
year routine tasks are more difficult
there he is wearing his mask I think all
of us are gonna have to get used to that
site I know I'm not going anywhere in
public these days in New York where I
can't maintain social distance you know
I go into Lowe's to get some wood I
gotta have my mask on the whole time
can't take it on and off and play around
with it on your face right you put it on
you keep it up all right so what's
Jonathan say well you use a more larger
ride on mowers he's relying on growth
regulators but it's really worried that
how's he going to provide these
consistent conditions that everybody's
gotten used to with less staff and less
fertilizer chemical imports I thought
very well-said for a quote pone at
office where well said Jonathan and and
I think this has got to be on
everybody's mind I mean I don't think
there's a golf course superintendent
running a golf course who's not thinking
about these same sorts of things whether
the grass is growing or not all right
let's look at some biology for a second
so and I'm sorry some climate weather
some climate data first
this is when we started the pandemic you
could see we were still in the 30s but
it looked like things were progressing
you could see here at the bottom the
onslaught of the warm soil conditions
temperature some some places in the 60s
all right now here it is a week later on
the 6th you can see oh now we're into
the mid 50s it's going to get going and
then BOOM
last week it's stalled and this week
it's calling backwards it seems to be
going backwards as of yesterday and and
you can see very little 50 degrees just
in some of the urban centers right maybe
that's around Rutgers we're all where
everybody's trying to cut the grass so
so obviously soil temperature has slowed
this is really good if you're gonna use
data this is the kind of data I would
start looking at because this is a
measure of how the soils gonna start
contributing to the whole effort to get
these plants growing now growing degree
days and monitoring how the season
progresses is another way to do it so
here's the forecast from the first week
the second week you could see we moved
into the double digit accumulation the
forecast that we just live through where
most of us had single digits and again
it looks like the majority of the
Northeast is gonna continue to
accumulate very few base 50 growing
degree days so so obviously that's a
stall based on what was happening now
you might embrace this if you're you
know trying to keep up and you might
curse it if now you've got more golfers
then you know you're used to now a point
to that roll in about traffic in a
second alright so where are we with
growth potential this is the same slide
I've used for three weeks in a row Carl
I haven't changed this slide one bit
because we're not even average in 50
degrees temperature Ben McGraw and our
conversation we're caught with Kyle
today starts out by this saying this all
right you were moving along it was going
good
everybody was gearing up fueling up how
we gonna make our adulticide apps and
look at look at the bed look at this
comment here in kyle this is the place
for us to chat now
uh this is the longest period between
initial ABW emergence and so and Pete
that I can remember so let me get to up
sorry about that let me get back here
and there we go are we looking at each
other yeah okay so Kyle obviously we
were progressive and you were on and you
were like you know we're not seeing
anything I sent you some scouting sheets
that Mike Hadley sent us from the
Bethpage black some of his scouting
routines and it's confirming what you
and Ben and everyone saying okay
it's slowed now one of the things that
is always on my mind is whenever these
guys get bunched up and I don't know
whether this is gonna bunch them up or
not but whenever they get bunched up and
then go out and have lunch at the same
time so to speak a lot of grass dies so
it makes an adult decide more important
but I wonder if it also makes it easier
to time cuz they're bunched up so that's
my thoughts let's let's hear from you
yeah that's that's a good question and
you know I think I think the sentiment
is really still being patient but
staying on your toes because of that
potential for things to accumulate
quickly it's pretty surprising what
we're seeing around Central New York I
think this time last year we reached
about 120 by the end of the month and
had peak adults by third or fourth week
of April but even in central New York
now we're still seeing around maybe
accumulation of 50 in the 50s for
growing degree days base 50 so you know
you don't want to get too complacent and
relaxed in that but you also don't want
to jump the gun especially if you're a
course that's down to say like 40
percent like you were citing earlier
from Jonathan's course there Frank
because I think that could could mean
people are getting caught off guard
we are seeing some sights though like
the data you shared with me Frank where
we're seeing peak adult activity already
downstate there couple courses where
I've heard that's the case but still
some other courses down in that area and
western mass that still seem like there
may be a whole week out before we're
seeing peak adults so so what does that
mean relative to timing you know okay if
you
don't have pyrethroids let's start there
if you don't have pyrethroids and you
can use pyrethroids as an adult decide
and I'm gonna get to that in my data
driven presentation in a minute some of
the work we've been doing but if you can
use pyrethroids how far do you think
most of us if when you say peak adult
that sounds to me like if I'm using an
adult decide I should get out there and
do it yeah for some courses where that
have you know the majority of those
adults out of overwintering sites I
would say that that's the time to do it
and you know but again I've seen a
couple courses where that seems to be
the case in other courses still maybe a
week to two weeks out from from that
actually happening okay so what about
the courses that have pyrethroids is
there anything they can use if they're
not going to use durr's ban which may or
may not be allowed depending on is that
allowed in New York State chlorpyrifos
yeah I mean it's allowed I think now
right now it's basically down to if you
have adults that are well if you're if
you're doing air blast sprays I think
you're limited right now you can't do
that but still you can use something
like an organophosphate so which I would
say is probably I'm a pretty good option
if you have something like Paris or a
resistance you know other other cases if
you've got every three resistance people
are suggesting maybe switching over to
may be focusing on level applications
only but again this is a tricky time for
that because if you're in a year where
every decision matters and your work
force matters where you're putting their
efforts in right syncing all your eggs
into doing lara sites only can be can be
a pretty risky thing to do
and unless you're interested in having
the weevil take out your PO and increase
a desirable grass that you'd rather have
it yeah and yeah that's the new thinking
on that yeah and there's been some
interesting interesting work from Albert
copenhefer looking at that possibly
where you've got low densities actually
using a BW to try and reduce pollen in
the system and he even admits there's a
lot more work to do in that regard and I
think I'd be pretty scary are you
endeavor to take on
you're useful so let's talk about
synchronicity right synchronicity about
you know the march of the weevils so to
speak you know they come out a little
bit they come out more and then there's
a wave of when they come out and again
like I said as we've come to learn about
curves right in this case we don't want
to flatten the curb or we do want to
flatten the curve can you talk a little
bit about an immediate emergence where
they all bunch up and what that would
look like versus you know something
that's prolonged and goes over a long
period of time yeah well I think one
important thing to note about that the
difference you might see there is if it
looks more prolonged which is kind of
what we're seeing right now that's when
you start seeing low numbers and wonder
oh is this the peak this must be the
peak but they're little lower so it's go
time and then a week later you actually
see what looks more traditionally like a
peak so so that can be where it's a
little more tricky to actually say what
the peak looks like but I think that's
where things like taking into account
phenological indicators and say do these
things jive and make sense together can
be really helpful and seeing go ahead
finish finish your point I was just
gonna say with some of those indicators
like forsythia we're still seeing that
most plants are in full bloom or are
close to that right now where we're not
seeing alignment with what you typically
see with time to apply against adults
okay so the other thing about it Kyle is
that when they all come out at once they
all feed at once the damage can be
severe they come out over a longer
period of time maybe the little sporadic
bit of feeding might be tolerable if
there's less traffic and you know the
golf courses may get less traffic just
by the general spacing we're gonna have
to do of the tee times and golfers to a
certain extent you imagine could mean
more carts I don't want to suggest
there's not going to be any stress if
we're open during this but but that's
the that's the traditional thinking
about it that if it comes out over a
long period of time I I might not have
to worry about it but in my head I'm
thinking well it was a mild winter I
could have a flat and long
curve that has a higher plateau yeah
yeah and that's a possibility you know
from I haven't been this in this as long
as some of the other turf entomologists
out there but what we've seen and every
year I've done it that weevil
development does catch up at some point
and that's where the sting on your toes
component I think really does play in
here because no matter how weird the
spring has been since since I've started
at some point they've caught up and that
larval development always seems to catch
up miraculously to you whether it's a
slow cold start or a really raging fast
start to spring so so it looks like a
lull right now where things are just
kind of idling slowly but I'm not gonna
be surprised if it catches up quickly
perfect alright Carl we got any
questions let's have some questions in
them we'll go on to the other part of
the of the of the time today so no
questions on a BW yet Frank so maybe
that's unless you got any more maybe
it's time to transition okay happy to do
that Kyle thanks for joining me
yeah thanks for having me I appreciate
that let me get this right let me get
this right we'll go right back to right
back to the right back to the videotape
is Warner wolf would say right back to
the videotape so again big shout out to
all of you that came together to form
this New York chapter the golf course
superintendents were so what a thrill to
be able to do one of the first education
events it's a very weird way to do we'll
always remember and have fellows so and
and and and and everyone else so so so
you know we'll always have this to to
look back on all right so so here you
know this wasn't the talk I was going to
give I wasn't anticipating a global
pandemic that shut us down we're in our
fifth week now here where I am so so I
thought this would be an apropos time
because you know I spent a lot of time
with an engineer my colleague and and an
assistant Karl skom NP and and it's
really before that with Bob Bob port
mess and it's really taught me a lot
about how to use data more and of course
I spent enough time close to
bilk riser and his work with growing
degree days that this has impressed me
as to be a whole way of looking at the
way we do it now inherently we've
resisted this I think that yeah day to
Frank I still got to see the place I
still got to feel things I still got to
smell things and such yeah I know it's
good to have sort of intuition that you
build from from your tactile experience
as you go out there your eyes and your
ears and your smells and the
temperatures and how you feel I mean
there's no doubt you've touching the
soil and measuring moisture we've done
this forever right but two things are
important now one is we may not have as
much as we used to and so we're gonna
have to be even more efficient than we
used to be which could include us so I'm
getting blisters again right but but
also we're gonna have to use our
resources more efficiently as we move
forward so I think the idea of using
data and blending it with your intuition
your inherent understanding your your
sort of knowledge of the property right
no one's saying being data driven
replaces being an intuitive
superintendent but I've also been around
long enough to say well we tell
ourselves a lot of things that's a lot
of phony-baloney sometimes and sometimes
our eyes can deceive us right sometimes
our eyes can deceive us so I think using
data neutralizes that to a certain
extent and it also of course in my
opinion will enhance it dramatically all
right so so the topic for today how do
we do this will allow for reducing labor
and resource consumption I guess that's
the way I'm approaching it to me that's
the value of it right you're gonna have
less labor and resource consumption I
don't think you're gonna be I don't
think anybody expects well I don't know
how people are gonna take if that leads
to less playable conditions what that's
going to mean III can't say what that's
going to mean I'm not sure anybody can
say what that's going to mean I think
everybody right now as we're adjusting
is just trying to well I'm gonna try to
get as close to what I usually do and
then I'm gonna get the greens and
everything is down the middle as quick
as I can and we've been here
from the USGA everybody about that but
essentially it may be a result of having
to deal with these two things all right
how would I approach it if it wasn't the
Cova thing well I wanted a little talk
about where this whole idea comes from
what's the history of and how do we
currently use it and how do we use it
again to help with copa-data is facts
and stats right I mean we you know that
we oftentimes say in science you can
torture the data enough and they'll tell
you anything they'll tell you anything
if it torture them enough and the
torture of data statistics right we
torture it with statistics why do we do
that well we do it to say listen I can't
study everything I gotta study this
little thing on this little plot of land
and then say well yeah this is the way
it is everywhere and we find out that
even if that's true in a small plot or
in one particular study 3/4 years it's
not always good for long periods of time
may not be scalable so that's the data
is not the all perfect situation but you
at least know what it is that it's a
reference point that you can analyze
something with all right what are you
trying to analyze well you try and
analyze something you can adjust adjust
what you're doing and predict moving
forward this is the hole this is the
dance you know there's a population
epidemiologist wrote an article called
hammer in the dance right the hammer is
the shut down of our society and the
dance is the little bit we're going to
be allowed to reenter it if we start to
reenter society the way we did in the
and the curb spikes again we're all
going back home right so we need to be
able to adjust what we're doing predict
what's going to happen and focus on the
growth of these our situation and the
way golf is playing to adjust and again
I have enormous hope because golf course
superintendents are inherently good at
this especially if you're not fighting I
have you know the obviously the less
financial pain you're experiencing in
this situation the easier it is to
absorb a lot of the things I'm talking
about but if your mind is burdened by I
don't know how I'm gonna pay five guys
or six guys or two guys or by
topdressing or by my fertilizer or get
that some snow molds application you've
got a lot of other things but if you can
determine exactly what you need use it
precisely it's gonna make you more
efficient you're gonna get the most out
of it fundamentally
that's what we're talking about right so
this is new to many people
so obviously you don't start out being a
data-driven manager but I'm I'm getting
jump I'm I'm getting all the statistical
I'm gonna do this right I'm I'm getting
on course I'm some of you are already
doing this with your workforce these
these digital workplace tables you're
already doing some of these things what
do you do well you're looking at little
data is describing something that
happens you work this many hours so far
last year and now you're working this
many hours so when Jonathan says I got
40% of the workforce he's using the
numbers he had last year in the numbers
he had this year to describe that says
okay you know I got this much less well
why did it happen and how did it happen
and how can I predict what I'm gonna
need and how can we improve it and how
do we go from looking back and saying
yeah I should have done that too looking
forward and saying yeah I think this is
the this is the right call and you're
not going to feel comfortable about it I
don't see how people are gonna be
feeling comfortable with making
decisions cold anyway never mind during
the pandemic so this is where data can
provide some foundation for your
decision-making anybody who knows me
knows I'm in somewhat of a sports
depression not because I really care
about any other sport but man I miss
baseball raise your hand if you miss
baseball I miss baseball it I'd be
sitting there every night watching it
forever so there we go that's the boy
I'm telling you I I miss baseball and if
you like baseball like I do you see how
the game has been totally transformed
totally transformed with data right and
so you know you're hitting the ball in
different places and your shift and you
do these things and so you see a game
completely transform so now all the
baseball teams are hire and all these
data scientists you know who then let
them to cheat ha I'm not gonna brag some
of these are Cornell IRR grads but many
of us don't have data scientists on our
staff at a golf course right so how do
you manage this sort of woman were
overwhelming amount of date well how's
the game begun to do this and listen I
could have given this
all talk about what I've learned
watching Carl scam auntie loose Stagner
and Mark Brodie and whoever else is
interested in the geekness of shots and
a game of golf I mean we could go down
that wormhole but you're and you see how
these things are being implicated by
officials and by players players or you
know you can put this thing on your club
and put your Ifill i watch on and then
it gives you your data of where you
normally hit and how your shots are and
what's the right way to approach the pin
and then it gives you follow-up stats at
the end so I don't know how many of your
golfers are using these things but these
things are out there the PGA Tour and
its strokes gain things you know you
know you ask you know my my pal Carl
here you know them has a picture that
describes his life he says he sends the
thing that aligns Club speed with
driving distances as the most important
thing and anybody that watches Carl
swing will know exactly what I'm talking
about so obviously there's a generation
of your players that are gonna come up
and and want to use your golf courses
that are thinking about this all right
so how do we currently use data just for
normal things and let's talk about ways
of using this during covert as well
well we currently use data for nutrient
management and you're balancing ions or
using minimum sufficiency levels you
know did you look at the GCS a survey
that said if you soil test more you tend
to apply more fertilizer and I think
many of us would say if you followed
minimum levels approach you wouldn't
apply that much fertilizer so sometimes
nutrient analysis takes us down the
wrong road I'm not suggesting all data
is good you have to discriminate like
and how do you convert data right
everybody uses this spectrum 300 you get
percent volumetric what's your number
2015 10 whatever it is right and then
you say well I how much water I don't
know five minutes how do you do that
conversion I've never heard about that
conversion so obviously you're doing
some data right now you're you're your
own walking computers and then of course
in a more serious note how do we use the
growth regulator knowledge that we've
amassed that it's been developing
quietly for the last decade
that's surprisingly very few people
still use or he even know about and how
do we use that all this stuff during
coke alright so you know I'm very fond
of the minimum levels for sustainable
nutrition is really probably our best
practice our best management practice is
to use this guideline in managing your
soil nutrient levels and determine from
here what you need and try to diagnose
any potential problems you might have
now at the same time you know you see
people bragging about using things like
phosphorus deficiency for growth
management no one's playing you don't
want to manage it right or if you're
playing and you want to keep it healthy
you don't have to over apply you see if
you go from three part per million to
five part per million very little
changes but then as soon as you get to
seven part per million and above your
perfectly green it's like a light switch
now I don't presume to know this but
this is the kind of data many of us
should be using we should be expanding
this data and mapping our soils now I
don't I don't presume to think anybody's
going to run out and do this now but
when we did this work at the Robert
Trent Jones Golf Course a number of
years ago with Andy McCullough wits and
Helena and there are x360 mapping plan
we did this when they were dragging the
plates around now they're dragging the
sled with an electromagnetic induction
device that's a different thing but no
matter how you get the data it's how you
interpret it if you in turn you know
here's your soil test levels for may
look three right and even if you just
use our old sufficiency levels that we
used to use at Cornell ten years ago
you'd have treated 70% of that fairway
right so now if you use the MLS n we
didn't have to put any phosphorus on so
these large-scale applications are
what's gonna get the hardest to do so
why do it just because you've always
done it why not do it based on data
moisture is that of course to me the
gold standard either the spectrum I like
the in-ground ones can you find moisture
management that allows the plants to
grow just at the rate you'd like them to
wouldn't it be great if you didn't have
to send the fairway mowers out in June
and July but one time a week is there a
way you can use
moisture management and wetting agents
to allow those longer drier periods
right whether you're buying water or not
right I mean one of the things you don't
want is these things growing like crazy
if you don't need them to now of course
the industry standard now for the way
growth regulators should be applied and
the many many hundreds and hundreds of
our algorithms and models that Bills
built for the different grasses that
we've talked about in these webinars you
know this is the foundation for using
plant growth regulators I would go so
far as to say if you're not using them
this way you're not using them right so
I guess you could say well you know I
don't follow this but I sort of do well
I don't know what sort of means I mean I
think there is wiggle room bill will
tell you in the way you can do this but
you shouldn't let it go into rebounds
especially in a year like this now Bills
of course got the green keeper app that
tracks all this for you big shout out to
him and Doug and the webinars that
they're doing this is a great place to
keep be mindful of data-driven stuff
listen you can't use data just by
looking at stuff you have to find ways
to bring it together manage it see it in
a readable form so that you can
interpret and make a decision
so however they visualize it whether
it's greenkeeper or or it's um it's it's
um greg Wujek playbooks whether it's
it's greg a whether it's playbooks or
greenkeeper on course whatever one
you're using right how are they
visualizing that data that's making it
easier to make your decisions that's how
you know you've got good data what data
do I need how do I put it together and
then what do I do when I'm looking at it
like this and we're gonna get into that
even further all right so what are
emerging methods of using data what are
ways that we can look at these factors
playability growth and pests right
during this global pandemic right and
adjust things and determine things that
are gonna then lead to us providing
known targets for plainness right we
know how to measure green speed I didn't
put green speed in there it's so old
right we know how to measure green speed
but
now we're measuring firmness and
trueness does that matter can we adjust
it what are the golfers think does it
help with traffic tolerance uh-huh
should we be doing that
what about growth nutrient demand and
traffic right you just want as much
growth and as and nutrients to support
that growth that keep up with your
traffic needs now those traffic needs
may be as minimal as whatever
maintenance traffic you have or as maybe
as you got two hundred rounds today
right and 200 rounds on any day causes
trouble well how are we doing that and
we'll go through of course some data
about clipping volume if you're not
doing it will encourage you to begin to
do it even though you might say well I'm
not gonna do it now I got less time well
my experience has been guys have figured
out how to do it with not taking much
time now from a pest perspective and
this is where we'll spend a little bit
more time I notice is where a lot of our
research is gone and what got me
thinking about this even more was the
ways we've used data to deal with the
things like we were just talking about
with Kyle as well as environmental risk
and risk of the pests
all right so recently Michael Woods
Cornell grad Michael Woods at the Asian
turf center tweeted out some surface
hardness of a grass species on putting
greens right where he's dropped the
clegg hammer thousand would he say for
almost three thousand clegg drops on a
hundred and six golf courses right now
you can see sometime you know he doesn't
have as many of each of these and you
can look at the data and find out more
but it's very interesting to see how
these firmness things look now there's
lots of ways of looking at this data and
you know what is this drop you know it
could be related to not many courses
I've heard people say right so but you
see you know parkland golf courses with
a lot of annual bluegrass might have
softer greens and fescue golf courses
out and the wide open with more sandy up
sandy places may have firmer greens and
then Paul Graham was was so kind to
provide some of the STR I data that was
also sort of tweeted back at Micah about
parkland golf courses and links golf
courses I
think it's interesting to denote where
they're measuring organic matter you
know you're talking about the top inch
this isn't the typical way we measure
organic matter in our you know what
people refer to as istrict tests that's
actually just an undisturbed core
analysis that undisturbed core analysis
typically gives us the organic matter in
the top you know zero to 60 millimeters
or seventy five seventy five millimeters
three inches right so so look at this
data and understand you know what does
this mean what am i trying to do and
then ultimately let's talk a little bit
about managing growth right this is the
little pamphlet Micah wrote the hashtag
on Twitter has a collection of of
solutions that superintendents have come
up with to do this easily so why is this
important to do what have we learned
from our own way of doing it at Cornell
now talk about this in the past to some
of you in the field the black bars are
the rainfall and this was two years
years ago in 2018 right so two years ago
we had a fair amount of rain we had a
fair amount of rain last year Dave hits
our golf course superintendent the
Robert Trent Jones Golf Course with Carl
cementy and the employee who does the
greens mowing in the morning we're
collecting the clippings from two
different putting greens right and so
you're looking at the five-day growth
average for the two greens and the
rainfall amounts and then one of the
things you begin to notice when you
start to look at data is if you look if
you look carefully you see the rainfall
and a bit of a peak and you see
persistent rainfall and you see a peak
now you see some rain you see persistent
rainfall and you see a little peak you
see some rainfall and you see a smaller
peak now obviously as you get into the
fall temperatures go down right so it's
cooler right but in the heat of the
summer on a growth regulator program
right just going through without making
any adjustments look at the clipping
volume fourfold over the or three three
or fourfold over the
demanded 10 to 15 milliliters per square
meter right tied up with rainfall which
is a measure of course of to a certain
extent the mineralization of nitrogen
and the availability of nitrogen now
looking at two greens we could see there
were some differences between the two
look like the poha Green our fifth green
with more annual bluegrass more shade
less air back going early we're seeing
we've seen some different responses
depending on the growing season but it
it's a you know we're not making any
adjustments yet we're just looking at
the data
well they've eventually wanted to look
at well what do I want during a
tournament right so he gears up every
year for the high school tournament at
the rtj and we were looking at clipping
volume and he really liked how it
performed when the clipping volume was
in this range here and it made me think
as I was putting this together Wow
wouldn't that be sort of what we'd want
for Cove it as a baseline if we don't
want to grow that much well there is an
also there I'm sorry there's also a
range that I'm not using here and it
Dave talks about you know playing you
know not not Cove it or not low growth
or championship conditions where I don't
want the grass growing very much right
but what's happening when I'm getting
played do what what kind of growth do I
need so I can target and tailor my
nutrient management my growth regulators
my moisture management if you have
control of it right what this graph is
saying here is sometimes you don't have
control of it it's moisture and even if
you're using growth regulators on a
model like we were using we still don't
have control you might have microclimate
differences it's hard to get control so
start to take the data and diagnose what
you want based on the traffic that's out
there now I put this in here Carl's done
some work looking at the mapping and how
it might help and I was wondering about
this now that if you had 40 carts you
could accommodate 80 golfers well now
unless those people are related or they
start putting plastic dividers and carts
you're gonna have 40 carts you're gonna
have 40 golfers I don't know what that's
gonna do or not going to do or if you're
gonna want to increase your volume let's
say I still got to have 80
offers now you got any carts where are
they going what are they doing how do i
target my nutrients based on where the
carts are going a very maybe some would
consider minor but I would say this is
probably where some of the biggest
traffic pressure is going to come from
because this is the part that could go
up and especially if we're starving for
revenue but we're gonna try to
accommodate my opinion as many carts as
we possibly can because obviously the
profit margin is pretty good on carts
all right let me get to some of the ways
we've used data to manage how are we
doing on time all right ten minutes I'm
doing pretty good all right many of you
know we started this project a long time
ago with the state parks here in New
York State we've continued to monitor
the golf courses over the last 1012
years on a wider on a wider scale and
what we've demonstrated is we've used
data to reduce risk associated with pest
management so we just said we can't have
this much risk on our pet on our state
park off courses for their pest
management programs so as many of you
know and I don't have to go into we use
the environmental impact quotient one of
the many risk models that are available
and I believe you're going to hear a lot
more about models in the future Carl and
Michael beckon Doug sold and I are
collaborating on a paper we're
presenting at the international
conference Michael beckon and and Carl
leading the way here on this work
Michael firs PhD at the University of
Wisconsin and they're looking at ways of
looking at environmental risk and and
weaknesses and strengths and ways of
using these models that are going to be
important moving forward playbooks has
incorporated it into their system so
again if you're going to have data
you're going to use data it's been good
to have an easy way to access it and so
hopefully the platform's continue to
integrate this into their use now you
can play around all the data I want but
ultimately the data most people care
about after cost is doesn't work it
might even be doesn't work and then how
much does it cost and of course you all
know we have the wonderful resource from
the University of Kentucky that we
talked about last week that's been
updated by Greg munch our Bruce Clark
Paul
right updated the most recent vin celeea
the PPA one with the efficacy chart
based on research so what are we doing
with the State Park reducing
environmental risk all right we figured
out from mining data that if we could we
could target what our problems were and
you find strategies to reduce its use
we'd be able to reduce overall risk and
one of the first things we found from
tar understanding our risk on our
pesticide use was to pests accounted for
as much as 60% of the total risk
associated with pest management on state
park golf courses in 2014 you can see it
went from 51 to 57 percent right so two
pests accounted for 60% of our overall
environmental risk so we said maybe we
should reduce our risk associated with
annual bluegrass weeble and we did and
we have two methods we used IPM for both
and especially for dollar spot risk
reduction models all right what are you
currently doing well Bannon Albrecht did
a survey many years ago and they said
the average number in the metropolitan
New York area number of fairways damaged
is 9 T's is almost 8 greens and collars
is almost 6 and many of you are making
about 5 and 1/2 pesticide applications
on Long Island golf courses right so if
we're talking about our data at Bethpage
this would be different everywhere but
that's a hot spot down there so what did
we do well we started looking you know
Mike Hadley was able to Scout just the
other day and get us numbers if you're
not scouting if you're not using people
like you know rod Ferrentino or you
other companies that come and do
scouting if you're not paying attention
to models and going and looking at your
own property
that's the first place to start that's
the first place to start is where is
that peak we were just talking about it
with Kyle about the peak well you don't
know if you're not out looking you've
got to keep those records and then you
choose products that are least toxic at
the best time now the implementation of
this trial that we did was you can see
we started out with
risk units as high as 2900 if you look
simply at the e I up sorry let me go
back if you look simply at the e IQ in
2012 we were as high as 2900 we were
treating as many as 39 acres o we were
treating as many as 39 acres and we were
making almost four applications a year
and over time you can see acreage risk
and number of applications have all
declined why did we even know to do this
we knew it because we started looking at
data the e IQ was a good place to start
but many of you know your area treated
and the number of applications that
you're making so we were able to drive
down the risk of the products we were
using over a period of time as well as
treating less acreage and that is how
you reduce pesticide use no matter what
your pest is you use least toxic
materials on smaller amounts of land now
once your fire way to reduce the need
for many applications is to a GPS
sprayer and we've worked with the frost
incorporated people we've worked with
frost Inc ken Ross out in Minnesota on
attaching this to the sprayer at skinny
Atlas Golf Club
Alex Hammond up there running the
facility you can see how the machine
comes on and off and when we got there
in 2017 they were treating 29 acres and
in 2018 we treated only 24 acres so just
by geometry they saw a 17% reduction
that's an easy way to do it especially
if you're trying to minimize use it took
them less time significantly they were
spraying at very high volume at very
slow ground speed so we were able to
realize an enormous reduction and when
you put all these things together every
time you spray you you spray less
acreage you spray less toxic materials
you push less pesticides on the ground
all of a sudden you're looking at 450
pounds now maybe before the global
pandemic that didn't matter
but maybe every pounds gonna matter now
so the end of my presentation talks
about using risk models now we've been
at this for a while for those of you who
do or don't use our forecast website a
lot of that work we started to do
because there were some dollar spot
models that were available that we were
playing around with before Smith Kearns
and we also had done some weather
climate data that we published back in
2007 that says the weather's getting
more conducive for dollar spot
especially in the fall especially in the
latter part of the season now we were
very fortunate that some more research
was done and the Smith Kern's model was
brought to the forefront and listen if
you're managing fairways in the
northeastern United States if you're in
New York off course superintendent I
can't imagine there's a disease you
spray more for than dollar spot on your
fairways both in the volume and the
number of sprays that you make and if
you're thinking about this that's when
this is most important if we're talking
about pest management on your putting
surfaces a lot of this stuff goes out
the window you're gonna have to focus
all the resources you have on keeping
those playing surfaces right around and
your surrounds as manicured as you can
possibly get I think it's these large
scale applications that if we had the
luxury to make them for a period of time
that it behooves us to use these models
and I'm looking at how we were back in
you know 2011 Carl's done a number of
things looking at the amount of dollar
spot pressure that we've had now one of
the things that's important when you use
these models is the threshold that you
use right 30 20 percent if you have a
resistant variety if you have a new
grass in there and this might be
something to consider if this whole
pandemic challenges you to think about
regressing why not plant disease
resistant Bank grasses or disease gray
leaf spot resistant ryegrass --is that
now allow you to have thresholds in the
50 to 60% range and you think about the
number of applications you have to make
when your threshold before disease comes
about is much higher
because you've got variety tolerance
you've got disease resistance in your
variety so again how you set the
threshold how much time you spend on it
and then the other thing that we've
learned more recently is the slope of
the line matters if the slope of the
line on the five-day rolling average is
on a steep incline you can ASSU and
you're let's go back here for a second
you see how this works with you know
you're getting a steep incline here
where the pressure is really bad but
thankfully you've made your first
fungicide application right so now you
go out 28 days you don't really have to
pay attention to the model I would hope
you get 28 days out of it let's hope you
do that would mean that you're not you
know gonna need it until here and the
model saying you're not too bad now all
of a sudden you start to see here and
here the slopes going right so it looks
like and of course you can come to our
forecast website and other places that
the line is getting steep so you bought
yourself what a week seven days you
bought yourself seven days and not
having a treat by using the model a
28-day material paying attention to the
slope of the line I got seven more days
look historically we have these models
it's it's it's something that's possible
to do we do a lot of this because of our
interaction with the Golf Estate park
golf courses on Long Island but you can
see out of the pressure is greater on
Long Island in general this is the
average dollar spot pressure across the
months of the year here we are in April
and May the the probability is very low
but soon will be higher right soon will
be higher how many times are you more
than a month where you need 30 days of
control well if you're on Long Island
you had 50 days you're applying on the
set interval if it's twenty-one days
you're applying on a twentieth day
twenty-first day you're not waiting till
20 to 23
unless you know you have the models to
cover you now as I wrap up I'll just
remind you that the world we're going to
live in may include us getting these
notices on our phone every day that
hey the Y just looked at the parameters
you're gonna set all the parameters
where are you what kinds of grasses do
you have do you have a history of these
problems and then it's going to look at
what it is today and what its gonna be
for the next few days and it's going to
say the disease resists your disease
risk is low it's going to be connected
to your last application and it's gonna
say your preventive is still effective
you're good you don't need to send
anybody in today the soil moistures
adequate and looks like it's going to be
so nobody into water today crabgrass
germination is still about three days
away alright I better get my pre down or
I'm gonna target where I'm going to do
it this is the world that's gonna make
the workforce the automation all the
things that are coming as a result of
this more important and I didn't even
touch on things like you know labor
deployment and daily course set up you
know innovations in how we're going to
apply things integrating these things so
just as we wrap up and maybe take some
questions call thank you all very much
and maybe call you put up the slide
other sponsors again and we take any
questions if there are any we're right
at the witching hour
one note Gabe was just saying that dubs
old that does have a clipping volume
Excel spreadsheet on his Wisconsin
turfgrass website so if you guys want B
the clipping volume spreadsheet he has
you can go find that I mean that no
questions no questions did I do that
good or I see you sure or your answer
them no questions just actually one from
Chris Richter what was that resource
about the cart sanitation BMPs
I think it was from New Jersey yeah the
New Jersey superintendent's if you go to
their Co vid website you drill into it
and you'll see there's some best
practices there and I actually think
this is written by two e-z-go people
that they're working with the jersey
association and i think you know call
this is really important that we get
together did that you know guys growing
grass get together with people who run
club al and we got to have a coordinated
effort for what are the best practices
for keeping everybody safe if we're
gonna not want to do to dance open and
then closed if the more we have these
standard operating procedures in place
the more we're going to be able to do
the dance and stay dancing as a medical
solution comes to pass yeah yeah so I
know no other questions again just a
quick shout out Frank I'm going to share
my screen with one more time yeah just
just to recognize all the sponsors who
made this happen right so again on
Dragonstone grassland heralds first turf
an ornamental those are the platinum
sponsors gold sponsors Finch turf pump
irrigation technologies BASF MTV and the
miss silver sponsor Syngenta and
nutrient solutions Ewing turf and soil
Weaver and Joe Jack's again thanks guys
and we'll be back again next week with
the second version of the webinar series
second episode Doug Sol that was
actually on today he'll be talking about
a little bit more in depth about
clipping volume nitrogen optimizing
those things again with anion coated so
thanks very much Carl see you later
everybody Tsugumi
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu